[Music]
[Applause]
uh let's bring in the uh
peripatetic tom e kern the patriots
insider nbc sports boston who joins us
on the program what was the difference
between the chargers game and last
night's game there tom
patriots got behind and when they are
behind cam
effectively ties their hands in being
able to rally because he is a
one-dimensional quarterback
against the charges they scored in the
first drive they came back they had a
block field goal for a touchdown they
had a pic
they had a punt return for a touchdown
party was over but in this instance
there was no digging out because
cam only can dig deeper it was a couple
of weeks ago i think when you wrote a
column
and you said that the patriots sort of
know what they have with cam newton
what is it and what's that mean for the
future
what it is is probably weirdly dan
it's the best case scenario for this
year because they are so
bereft of offensive weaponry and you see
it during these games i don't know if
anybody would be getting a hell of a lot
more out of it whether it was kyle
murray or russell wilson tom brady or
cam newton
they're so challenged at the wide
receiver spot so what you have in newton
is a guy who can run for 11 touchdowns
who can be a red zone threat who can
pick up third and twos by pulling
forward
but you pay the price otherwise so they
know
that you can't have him at least in my
estimation bill might
think differently but this is an
anachronistic offense it's a 1950s high
school offense where you just have the
biggest kid on the block and say
he's going to run you over and then if
the other team has a good kid too from
the other neighborhood
you're screwed that being aaron donald
that being aaron donald or that being
well not even jared goff but that being
desean watson
or it being a coach i think really too
was a fair fight
on the sidelines that bill was engaged
in last night
sometimes he can just big brain the
opposition
and last night i don't think was that
was the case
all right so what's the goal do you
think with this team for the rest of the
year
what it should be excuse me is making
sure that
they know what they have going into the
20 21 off season they have like 60
million dollars in cap space
they're probably going to be a top 15
selector they should know whether or not
jared stidham can play
even a little they should be able to
figure out who defensively is going to
be there going forward
and figure out what pieces they'll need
instead i think they're going to spend a
fair amount of time
trying to well you have to try and win
the miami game you still get a shot
but going forward and into 2021 they
have to address the quarterback position
it's the most important position in
sports stand
but really since they traded garoppolo
they've cast it about
for any solution at all danny yetling
and stidham are the only guys they
drafted at the spot
hoyer and newton are the only guys
who've held down the spot
and 2017 halloween was three years ago
yeah don't they know what they haven't
statum and and if they don't why aren't
they going to play him now
they suspect what they have he is no
barrier to them having any future plans
at the spot
meaning that he wouldn't even if he went
off
the next three weeks i don't think that
that would stop them from doing anything
why won't they play him now bill is
getting that question over the last 12
hours and both times he's bristled today
said i'm not answering that question
ever again
but uh i think that they're looking at
it as you got to dance with what brought
you he gives us a chance
to score points cam does if the rest of
the game falls a particular way
if i may have to fall that way if i made
you the gm
what would you do
um i would probably
say bill it's a good idea to go ahead
and use uh
stidhum you know lose this game against
miami and then we go sit on the last two
we finish uh seven and nine um
you can't desert the players and say
we're going to stitum to find out what's
going on when there's still a
mathematical chance
i think that would be especially this
year where guys are sacrificing so much
um and a front but i would probably go
after
jimmy garoppolo jacoby brissette
bridge guys until you can find the
answer
at quarterback well garoppolo wouldn't
be a bridge
no you're right i said that and i said
we can get that back
especially since he's been so overpaid
in san francisco
that's going to be fascinating to watch
too because if you're a matt stafford if
he gets released or jimmy garoppolo or
whoever
do you want to come to new england i
mean this attractive place for 20 years
you're going to look at it and go who am
i throwing to again you guys got to sign
a tight end at some point
and i wouldn't be dying to come here to
finish my career and chase a ring
yeah and and i while i can credit
belichick for
doing some pretty good coaching this
year i can also blame belichick
for having to do some really good
coaching because he doesn't have the
personnel
right and that's why conversations about
whether or not he's coach of the year
come with that caveat
well look what he's done with cam well
why is cam here it's because he held the
door and tapped his foot until brady
walked through it
hashtag tommy
do you think brady watches do you think
he watched that game last night
yeah he likes football do you think he
watches it
with a smile on his face at any point
that's a good question i think um
no i don't think he smiles relative to
the players on the field
but i think that there's probably a
satisfaction that he takes in saying see
see i didn't throw four touchdowns and
ten picks i still somehow threw 24
touchdowns with these guys and i was
supposed to be the bad guy in decline
then of course he has a game this
weekend he's not been lighting the world
on fire either
no if we talk in a month from now
about the patriots what are we talking
about well they finished eight and eight
and
it's weird but it's january 10th and
they're not in the playoffs
and they're starting to try and make
their decisions you have to figure out
whether patrick chung and
dante hightower and marcus cannon and
james white i mean they've got a lot of
guys stand who are free agents
not just where the roster is right now
and not just how much cap space they
have there a lot of
old lions on this franchise that are
free agents so
i don't even know if the rebuild has
started could you see bill ever coaching
a different team wesleyan lacrosse
that's it not in the nfl no
no i don't i don't i don't see that
happening i don't know if you could kick
upstairs and be a consultant and have
stephen belichick perhaps be a head
coach or
you know mayo or someone like that but
i really think that and he is such a
detail-oriented guy dan and
you know dealt with them i just don't
think he would want to walk away and
give anybody the satisfaction of saying
yeah well
bill drove the team into the ground at
the end once brady left
i think he would be stubborn enough to
say no i'm not going anywhere
thanks for joining us as always tom we
appreciate your time and uh
happy holidays as they like to say buddy
thanks my friend
say hi to michael that's a tom e curran
patriots insider nbc sports